named after the ancient roman goddess of
beauty
venus is known for its exceptional
brightness in the night sky
but behind this facade is a world of
storms and infernos unlike anywhere else
in the solar system
venus the second planet from the sun is
very similar to earth from a distance
but up close it's a very different world
venus is about the same size as earth
just slightly smaller
its structure is also nearly identical
with an iron core a hot mantle and a
rocky crust
the crust of venus however is dotted
with thousands of volcanoes including
maxwell montes a volcano almost as tall
as mount everest
venus also has a thick layered
atmosphere
it's full of clouds that rain sulfuric
acid and whip around the planet at
speeds up to 224 miles per hour
faster than some category 5 hurricanes
the atmosphere is so thick that it
creates a surface pressure similar to
what it would be about half a mile deep
in the earth's oceans this pressure is
heavy enough that a human standing on
venus's surface would be crushed
the atmosphere is made of greenhouse
gases primarily carbon dioxide which
create an extreme case of global warming
they trap the sun's heat causing surface
temperatures to rise over 880 degrees
fahrenheit
making venus the hottest planet in the
solar system
venus is so inhospitable neither humans
nor spacecraft are able to survive the
planet's surface
but some scientists speculate that venus
wasn't always so unwelcoming
from roughly 2.9 billion to 715 million
years ago global temperatures on venus
may have been just a few degrees cooler
than earth's are today
and scientists theorized that the
surface may have contained shallow
oceans that could have held enough water
to support life
today life may still exist in venus's
atmosphere
about 30 miles up in venus's clouds
where the temperature and surface
pressure are similar to those on the
surface of earth scientists have
observed strange dark streaks that
appear to be absorbing ultraviolet
radiation a phenomenon that could be
evidence of microbial life
life may struggle to survive in the
atmosphere of venus but it is this
unforgiving environment that's made
venus an icon of beauty
it reflects 70 percent of all the
sunlight that reaches the planet which
is why venus shines more brightly than
any other planet or star in the night
sky
while more than 40 unmanned spacecraft
have visited this infernal world
venus
so illuminated in the darkness of space
still has much to reveal
[Music]
you